i know that's not really how the show
works but
jazz i need you to help me get on the
dance team you don't dance at all
this movie was so much freaking fun in
your opinion though like what do you
feel sets this movie apart from other
dancing movies probably our cast
probably our our diverse cast in so many
ways and all the different characters
and what they bring in their special
talents and
um and also just like the sense of the
humor that the movie has and the fact
that it is very like
present and it doesn't take itself too
seriously but we're also
very hard-working characters it can
hopefully be um
good inspiration for young people who
are also working really hard towards a
goal and
and might be losing a little bit of
faith or steam during these hard times
and knowing that
um it's not a race um but it's it's a
journey
it ain't no sprint it's a marathon and
we are in the long run honey
and i think just allowing yourself to
you know dive into the movie and feel
like you're a part of it with us i hope
people see themselves in the characters
and see themselves in the movie too
i think that's what the movie is all
about is just redefining yourself and
having fun recreating yourself
and allowing yourself to you know kind
of lose control mr elliott style
everybody here get it out of control
a lot of very fun moments watching your
guys characters navigate
romance in the movie you think i don't
see you staring at jake like he's a pop
quiz
untrue what is quarantine dating
like for each of you it's liza's on
every dating service
uh app available
i mean i i had a good time you know
reminiscing about my times on set
with the magnificent drew ray tanner who
plays
shirtless mattress guy in the movie uh
sure but i feel like
i'm just like going back in time and
thinking like
damn i should have gone on some days in
toronto but
but hey we're doing zoom games zoom
dates are fun too as i was gonna say
like most of my quarantine
dating has just been lies uh no um
uh no it's it's uh it's such a weird
time right now especially for like
feelings are all over the place we are
just all trying to
figure it out and figure out how we're
feeling and prioritize our health our
mental health our sanity and
um yeah i mean it's been it's been a
weird time for everybody but
uh no i mean i'm not i'm not on the
zoom dating circa currently
alicia keys executive produced this
movie did you guys have any time with
her
i mean we went to her killer grammy
party which was basically just liza and
i just
you know fangirling over our ep she's so
wonderful and such an incredible human
in so many different ways that
having her be a part of this film in
every in any way at all
is is a gift and um and we're excited
for
uh for people to see that but also just
like
she's such a wonderful person to look up
to for both of us as young women in the
industry so
that was really special he's such a
superwoman she roots for the underdogs
and you know to be given the chance to
be a part of such an amazing production
and work alongside sabrina it's
an honor speaking of dancing i mean
jordan fisher your guys's co-star
he has quite the long relationship with
dancing with the stars would either of
you guys ever do
dancing with the stars yes yes
that was a quick yes i'm like preparing
myself because i got tendinitis from
doing a two-month dance film let alone
like a full
dance show i'd have to think about it
but it's definitely something that i've
always looked at and been like god
that'd be so
fun you know but like i can do like some
of the things and then there's other
ones that i'm like i don't know if salsa
and i go together
you know what i mean both of your guys
dance moves in this movie and you guys
can both freaking dance
okay whatever you say audition for
graduate studies i'll do it
if i can realize that liza and i can be
partners i know that's not really how
the show works but
new times yeah sabrina your run and mean
girls on broadway got
cut really short i wouldn't call it a
run more of like a
bus stop well
will you be back when broadway reopens
that is the goal i
i grew such a family in such a short
period of time with with the mean girls
crew
and uh and with tina and jeff and just
everybody involved like i really felt
part of the family which was very
special and to only do two shows was
such a bummer because by show too i was
like yeah let's do this forever and then
it was like
just kidding um and i'm not doing it now
uh for a while but
hopefully that is the goal is to be able
to return at some point
when all the shows return and hoping
that sooner than later because we miss
broadway a lot
yeah i mean they're going to turn the
musical into a movie so would
do you want to be part of the movie if
they call me up i will answer that call
yeah yeah we will have some negotiation
just got no kidding oh no
i'm such a fan of the people involved
with mean girls all around so i trust
that whatever they're doing is going to
be
magnificent and playing katie herron on
stage has been so fun so i can only
imagine like what uh what getting to do
more with that character or what that
film would be like